[موسيقى]
حياته مع رفيده ياسين على العربيه
انا رفيده ياسين وهذه هي حياتهم على
العربيه
واليوم سنحلق سويا للتعرف على عالم غريب
ومختلف وتحديدا في اندونيسيا حيث تعيش
قبيله داني الغريبه والمختلفه ومن ابرز
عاداته انها بتدبر النساء على قطع اجزاء
من اصابع
للتعبير عن الحزن الشديد في حال وفاه احد
افراد الاسره وده بهدف جعلهم يشعرون بذات
الالم العاطفي ولكن بطريقه جسديه لانه ما
كفايه بالنسبه لهم الشعور بالحزن نفسيا او
عاطفيا لابد ان يقترن هذا الحزن والالم
بالالم جسدي للتاكيد على الشعور بالاسى
عند رحيل احد الغاليين من افراد الاسره
العمليه دي بتتم في الطقس بتتجمع فيه
افراد الاسره والجيران والاقارب عند وفاه
احد مهم وبيتم ربط اصابع المراه بحبل رفيع
حتى يتم تخديره ثم بيقطع جزء من احد
الاصابع والعمليه دي بتكون مؤلمه الى حد
كبيره ولكن ده هو الهدف من اجراءات وشعور
المراه بالالم وقد تتكرر هذه الحادثه او
هذه العمليه كل ما يموت شخص غالي او عزيز
من الاسره في كل مره بيتم قطع اصبعه
بعيدا عن العالم الخارجي وصبغه تعقيداته
وتفاصيل الكثيره وضعت قبيله داني لنفسها
دستور الخاص وتمسكت من خلاله بعاداته
وتقاليده اللي بتثير الدهشه تارا وتثير
الغابه تاره اخرى
ومع الغوص في اعماق معتقدات القبيله دي
بتظل كل تعبيرات الاندهاش قليله امام
تصرفات ابناءه سواء بدايه من قيام النساء
بقطع اصابعهم مع فقدان كل عزيز
والاحتفاظ بمحاربيهم القدام من خلال اجراء
عمليه تحنيط ولكن بالتدخين
بالصدفه وجد رجل الاعمال الامريكي ريتشارد
ارشغلت الهاوي والمغامر للتعرف على
الثقافات الاخرى وجد نفسه محاط بالقبيله
المعزوله دي عام
ومنذ منتصف القرن العشرين اصبحت قبيله
داني فريده من نوعه
ومعروفه بشعور القوي بالهويه
وحرصها على الحفاظ على تقليده بحكم انهم
بيتمسكوا بطرقم التقليديه حتى اظهار امام
الزائرين على انها جزء مهم من ثقافتهم
وتقاليدهم العادات والتقاليد عموما بتختلف
في كل بلد باختلاف ثقافته وباختلاف البيئه
المحيطه لانه البيئه اثر وتاثر وتعد
العوامل البيئيه والمناخيه من العوامل
الاساسيه لتكوين ثقافه الشعوب وبالتالي
انماط الحياه اللي بيعيشوها وبيتبعوها في
حياتهم وبمارسه فيها قسم في قبيله داني
الطقوس دي تعتبر مقدسه وغير قابله للتغيير
اول الغاء او حتى اي محاولات لتمسحها
المستكشف الالماني ماركو صراف فود هو
الاخر عند محاوله لاكتشاف هذا العالم
الغريب في قبيله داني بالعادات والشعائر
المختلفه اللي وجد داخل القبيله
الاندونيسيه الشهيره والامر تتدفعوا لقضاء
اسبوع كامل وسطهم يتعرف على المزيد عن
حياتهم اليوميه
وتفاصيل نمط بيئتهم المختلفه وجد الشعب ده
معزول نوعا ما عن العالم الخارجي لكنه
ترحاب ويرحب بالزائرين القادمين للتعارف
بسلام على ثقافتهم او الراغبين في اجراء
مغامره سياحيه للتعرف على ثقافات الشعوب
الاخرى
اكتشف بعض ماكولات ومهاراتهم الحياتيه
الاساسيه بالاضافه لطقم شهد ايضا عادات
غير المتوقعه اللي بتتبعه القبيله وبخلاف
انه بتقدم على قطع اطراف اصابعهم العلويه
بنفسهم تعبيرا عن الالم والحزن كان اكثر
التفاصيل اللي اثارت الدهشه داخل القبيله
وجود مومياء في وسط المكان اسمها كورولو
المومياء دي تابعه لقبيله داني ويقال انه
عمرها لا يقل عن 370 سنه افراد القبيله
بيحتفظ بمحابيهم القدامى ويمكن ده كان
يكون اهم محارب ومقاتل قديم بتعتز القبيله
بشجاعته بسالته من خلال المعارك اللي خاض
حفاظا على ارضه وبيته وثقافه مجتمعه
تحميطا المحاربين القدامى والاقوياء بيكون
رمز للفخر والاعتزاز بما خاضوه من بساله
في المجتمع وبتكون مصدر لروايات الجدات
للاديان الجديده عشان يعرفوا تاريخ هذه
القبيله والتضحيات اللي بذلوها اجداد من
الدفاع عنهم وللحفاظ على بيئتهم ومجتمعهم
وتقاليدهم القبيله بتستخدم عمليه التحنيط
عن طريق التدخين للحفاظ على جثث الاجداد
ورغم ان الاسلوب ده اصبح نادر ممارسه الان
الا انه لا تزال القبيله تحافظ على عدد من
المومياوات داخل المجتمع وفي وسط المكان
كرمز لاحترام لاسلافهم وللتعبير عن
تاريخهم بطريقه عمليه
مجتمع مختلف في هناك بيتميزوا بالخجل
والغرابه مزيج وخليط غريب في الوقت نفسه
بيتمتعوا بالشجاعه ايضا وبيعيشوا بعيدا عن
كل مظاهر الحياه العصريه
وبيقوم كل التفاصيل الحديثه اللي بتكون
دخيله على حياته ونمط حياتهم الريتيني
بيزرعوا كل ما يحتاجوه وبيعتمدوا على
التجاره بين القرى في كل احتياجاتهم ولا
يزالوا بيمارسوا الطبخ باستخدام النار
والحطب وبيعيشوا بشكل منفصل في منازل
مخصصه للنساء واخرى لرجال صحيفه ديلي ميل
البريطانيه اعده التقرير عن قبيله داني
للتعرف اكثر على ملامح حياته واقتربت من
عالمهم عشان تتكلم عن عاداتهم بطريقه اعمق
عن قرب وكان من العادات الاخرى الغريبه
الخاصه في الملابس
رجال القبيله بيرتدوا قطعه واحده صغيره في
الجزء السفلي من اجساده وهذه الملابس
بتسمى كتيكا وتقوم بتصنيع النساء وخاصه
الكبيره في السن بيتفنن في العمل عليها
بطريقه يدويه اما النساء فعلهم وجهه نظر
متحرره تجاه الملابس
وبيرتدوا تنانير مصنوعه من الالياف
الساحليه المنسوجه والمزينه بالاكياس
والقش وبتلبس المراه في الراس ما يسمى
بنوكن وده بيكون واحده من علامات الجمال
اللي بتميز النساء في قبيله دانيه رقصه
المحارب من اهم العادات ايضا وبتنظم
القبيله في شهر اغسطس من كل عام احتفال
لاقامه معارك وهميه مع القبائل المجاوره
وبتحضر كل القبائل من هداني ويالي ولاني
وكل قبيله بتحضر افضل المحاربين الشجعان
والشباب الاقوياء البنيه عندها لخوض هذه
المعركه الوهميه واظهار ثقافتهم الغنيه
للاحتفال
بالاطفال
ولتعريف بانه ده مستقبلهم عندما يكون رجال
لابد ان يكونوا محاربين اقوياء لدعم
عاداتهم وتقاليدهم وبتقام فيها ايضا
احتفالات بترقص فيها رقصات شعبيه وتقام
فيها الاغنيه اللي بتكون باللهجات المحليه
عالم يمكن سمعه مخيفه بين القبائل الاخرى
يمكن تكون مختلفه ثقافه بالنسبه للكثيرين
الا انهم يفتخر بعاداتهم وتقاليدهم
وبيعتبر من اشهر الصيادين وقبيله ودوده
ومضيافه رغم حرسها على الانغلاق والبقاء
بعيدا عن عالم الخارجي عالم مختلف يمكن
يكون مقبول او مرفوض عند اخرين لكن يبقى
مصدر اختلافه عاداته وتقاليده ببساطه لان
هذه هي حياتها
[موسيقى]